RETO MEIER: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted 100% of your daily
recommended intake of talks
detailing the future of cloud.
If you didn't get a chance
to catch the session Using
Google App Script
to Automate G Suite,
then stay tuned, because
here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
App Script is a serverless
JavaScript runtime
for G Suite automation,
extension, and integration.
COLT MCANLIS: Which
is a fancy way
of saying that your script
runs when you need it to
without you needing to provision
servers for it to run on.
RETO MEIER: App Script code
is written in JavaScript,
and it runs within a
sandboxed interpreter that
provides access to
our APIs and services.
COLT MCANLIS: Most
importantly, App Script
makes it extremely easy
to enhance G Suite to meet
your business needs.
For example, you
can use App Script
to help you do things like
automate document approval,
simplify and create
dashboards, user provisioning,
and pretty much
everything in between.
RETO MEIER: There are a
number of entry points for you
to start using App Script
within your organization.
The first is Docs, Sheets,
and the Forms script editor.
We call scripts created this
way container-bound scripts,
or just bound scripts.
You can easily create
simple trigger functions
that respond to changes
on the document.
For example, on Open or on Edit.
Within Sheets, you can
create custom functions
that work just like
the built-in functions,
but are implemented as
JavaScript in your script.
Now, if you are looking
for a script that
attaches to a document
like a bound script
but could be attached to
many different documents,
you're probably
looking for an add-on.
COLT MCANLIS: The
second entry point
is through the cloud IDE
at script.google.com.
This is ideal for
scripts that aren't
tied to a particular document.
That could include anything
from one-off utility scripts
to web app scripts and add-ons.
You can think of
these as bound scripts
that can be bound
to any document
by any user who installs it.
RETO MEIER: Now, the
final two entry points
are a little bit
more specialized.
You can build AdWord scripts
to automate your AdWords
campaigns, or use scripts within
App Maker, which is currently
still in beta.
COLT MCANLIS: In each case,
the built-in App Script's API
provides access to
other Google or GCP APIs
as advance services,
simplified AJAX,
and Stackdriver integration.
RETO MEIER: If you'd like
to know more about what's
possible with App
Scripts in G Suite
and see some live coding
examples of how simple it
is to implement, check out
the full session video.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the Google
Cloud Summit coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]